it's a millionaire theme our on the Dave
Ramsey show Terry is next in Denver hi
Terry how are you I'm wonderful this is
fulfilling a dream I've always wanted to
be on yourself thrilled well I'm glad
you're here what's your net worth one
point for cool and how old are you 70 to
72 and what is the one point for consist
of well I've got 420 and Vanguard mutual
funds and IRS and I've got a hundred
thousand and a thrift savings program
because I was a government employee and
about 70 K and checking and a 529 fund
for my relative mm-hmm
where's the rest of it that's it that's
about nine well my house is worth about
200 K and then I've got 80,000 and
checking and emergency fine
okay gotcha gotcha how much of this one
point four million did you inherit
nothing zero okay how much of it did you
steal from people
what was your average income or you're a
household range of income through your
working lifetime
I'm a retired teacher I started out 40
years ago at 5,000 and the most money I
ever made in a year was fifty thousand
Wow so you're just a master saver aren't
you I am I love to bargain and live
below my means well so your degree was
in education yes elementary education
I've got my masters and gifted education
to work with kids like you smart what
was your GPA in college well actually I
flunked out the first year in
undergraduate due to learning
disabilities that were on diagnosed and
then I went back and got a 3.0 in my
master's program good for you wow that's
cool so how much of the 1.4 million is
there because you borrowed money and
turned that into wealth I couldn't live
on the two part-time jobs that I had in
college so I borrowed for it
five thousand dollars in a student loan
and I work two jobs the first two years
of teaching so I could pay it off
tomorrow did you borrow to invest ever
never okay all right cool very cool you
did it you're a millionaire
congratulations thank you I love it it's
an honor to talk to you very very fun
one of the America's Heroes the starts
from nothing she's a teacher never makes
over fifty thousand dollars in her life
and as a net worth at seventy two of one
point four million dollars it can be
done you just make these choices
way to go Terry I'm glad to talk to you
this is the Dave Ramsey show on a
millionaire theme hour hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show you can do
this you know that really is a message
whether you've got two hundred seventy
thousand dollars in student loan debt or
27 thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar in the car